[Musique]
François Begodo, bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Serview. Est-ce
que vous pouvez vous présenter
succintement ?
François Begodo écin.
Vous connaissez la chaîne YouTube
depuis combien de temps ? Je crois que
je l'ai découverte il y a 3 4 ans
et je crois que depuis j'ai dû voir
aller les 3/4 des entretiens. Ouais,
monsieur.
Bienvenue à la maison.
Ça fait tellement plaisir de voir la
famille.
Bon, trêve de plaisanterie, le sujet qui
nous intéresse. Euh, on peut se tutoyer
direct. ta capacité à analyser la prise
de contrôle de la dialectique par nos
politiques. Qu'est-ce que tu penses de
cette nouvelle novel langue qui émerge
pour prendre le contrôle de la
dialectique en général ? Ce
travestissement de la langue française ?
Je pense que c'est quand même un peu une
vieille affaire que les pouvoirs
imposent une langue, déforme la langue,
paradisite la langue et essaie surtout
de créer des courts-circuits entre un
signe, un signe verbal et son référent,
c'est-à-dire ce qu'il dit. Ils ils
mettent des courtscircuits. C'est comme
ça. C'est le c'est le principe de toute
falsification parce que je pense que le
pouvoir est fondamentalement
falsificateur. Je c'est pas c'est pas ça
c'est pas d'hier. Alors ce qui est vrai
que ce qui est un peu fascinant par
rapport à notre époque maintenant c'est
que la novel langue elle est issue du
management. Ça c'est surtout ça moi qui
me frappe.
Bon Bourdu on avait déjà fait le
diagnostic à la fin des années 70 donc
tout ça est pas nouveau. Disons que je
pense qu'avec avec l'arrivée de Macron
alors définitivement le management a été
installé au pouvoir et sa langue mais c
sa langue avait déjà infiltré tout un
tas de domaines. Moi je je le raconte
assez souvent. La première fois que je
me suis rendu compte de la façon dont la
langue managériale était en train
d'infiltrer tout un tas de domaines,
c'était c'était pas dans une entreprise
parce que j'ai jamais bossé dans le
privé en tout cas pas strict auensu.
C'était pas je dirais dans une start-up
ou que sais-je, c'était dans l'éducation
nationale où j'ai passé 10 ans et là
j'ai vu arriver la rhtorique du projet
par exemple dont Franck Lepage a a su
bien traiter le problème.
Donc c'est ça, je pense que tout
transformer en transformer un pays en
entreprise, bon bah c'est tout de suite
c'est une langue qui permet de
redessiner les contours du champ social.
Bon, alors c'est vrai que là-dessus tous
les citoyens peut-être à forcerie des
intellectuels, s'ils peuvent servir un
peu à quelque chose, si on leur attribue
une certaine compétence pour parler
comme les managers
sur les mots, bah peut-être que les
intellectuels peuvent aider à
déconstruire la déconstruction,
à remettre un petit peu de de réel dans
la falsification générale.
La guerre, c'est la paix.
La guerre, c'est la paix. J'aime bien
tes tes aismes de Laoutseux. Euh je
dirais et inversement hein, ça marche à
tous les coups et inversement. Euh
bon, il y a cette vieille idée que la
guerre et la politique continu par
d'autres moyens. On peut dire aussi que
la politique et la guerre continu par
d'autres moyens. Enfin, ça marche dans
tous les sens. C'est que en tout cas ce
que je retiendrai de tout ça close et
compagnie c'est que et ce qui me semble
très important et tout à fait une
contreindication à je dirais au
macronisme ou au libéralisme en général
d'ailleurs, savoir que le champ social
est toujours conflictuel. Voilà, un
champ social, c'est un champ de rapport
de force et que toute idéologie qui nous
dirait bon ce qu'on voit bien avec le
grand débat en ce moment, mais çaen est
que disons un nouvel épisode qui
comprend beaucoup beaucoup de chapitres
antérieurs
à savoir qu'on va se mettre tous autour
d'une table et discuter et trouver des
points d'accord et des compromis, ça
c'est ni ce que c'est qu'un champ
social, ce que c'est qu'un corps social.
Dans un corps social, il y a des
intérêts qui sont contradictoires et les
intérêts des uns ne sont pas les
intérêts des autres. Ce qui fait
qu'évidemment les intérêts des uns bien
seront défendus au dépend des intérêts
des autres. Moi, je suis toujours un
petit peu en en petite perplexité
théorique avec mes amis de gauche quand
il parlent beaucoup de l'intérêt
général. Alors, c'est une belle notion
l'intérêt général chez Rousseau. Elle a
une profondeur et une complexité
passionnante.
Mais je crois que ça masque parfois
l'idée que
justement il y a pas d'intérêt général à
proprement parler. C'est-à-dire qu'on
pourrait dire que l'intérêt général, bon
des terriens actuellement, c'est que la
planète survive ou que les vivants
survivent sur la planète. Ça on pourrait
dire, on pourrait s'entendre sur cet
intérêt général là, sauf que dès qu'on
commence à en parler, bah on s'aperçoit
qu'il y a quand même des pollueurs et
des pollués. En tout cas, il y a des
pollueurs euh disons des céréal
pollueurs et puis des gens qui subissent
plus la pollution qu'il ne l'a qu'il ne
l'exerce. Euh et puis on s'aperçoit que
si on veut vraiment sauver le vivant et
ben il va falloir quand même mettre hors
d'état de nuire les maxipoleurs qui
peuvent être des États, qui peuvent être
des multinationales. Enfin, on connaît
bien tous on connaît ces criminels en
série. Donc euh c'est très important de
rappeler que la politique c'est le
conflit. Il n'y a de politique à partir
du moment où X dit à Y, je suis pas
d'accord avec toi et quelque part, il va
bien falloir que enfin ça ce soit peu la
guerre mais en tout cas une sorte
d'affrontement
parce que ben oui, d'une certaine
manière, la façon dont tu occupes la
cité est contradictoire avec la façon
dont moi j'aimerais l'occuper. La façon
dont des adistes essaient d'occuper la
cité, la cité au sens large hein, est
contradictoire avec le fait que des gens
aient voulu mettre un aéroport, bétonner
les zones humides qu'il y avaient sur ce
territoire. Je pense exemple mais je
pourrais en prendre 4000.
On a été faire un petit tour à la à la
ZAT de Notredame des Landes où
d'ailleurs on a été très bien reçu et
on a vu ce que c'était de près.
Le Zadiste est hospitalier
est très très
et et très accueillant.
Ils font du très bon pain d'ailleurs et
des très bonnes pâtes. Désolé pour cette
petite parenthèse. On reprend on reprend
les notes. Euh le populisme euh
c'est une façon de discrédité par les
mots. C'est c'est un travestissement
encore de la langue française ? C'est un
constat factuel ? C'est quoi ?
Il faut voir pourquoi ce mot, ce mot
n'est pas nouveau. Ce mot pourrait avoir
un sens un peu pertinent si on en
regarde l'historicité. Bon, je je passe
là-dessus. Quel est son usage depuis 10
ans de façon frénétique dans le champ
public et notamment du côté des
éditorialistes, du côté du pouvoir ?
C'est un sens de disqualification et
notamment de disqualifier à peu près
tout ce qui n'entre pas dans disons
l'ordre libéral, hein, l'ordre dominant.
Euh alors en fait, on pourrait dire
selon la bourgeoisie, ce que moi
j'appelle la bourgeoisie et bien bien
une effidition du populisme, ce avec
quoi je ne suis pas d'accord, ce dont je
mouvement dont je perçois qu'il pourrait
me nuire et qui pourrait me contester.
Ce qui fait qu'il y a eu une espèce
d'extension du domaine du populisme. Il
y a encore 10 ans, on disait populisme,
il y a même encore 5 ans seulement, je
le dis dans mon livre Histoire de ta
bêtise là que je viens de sortir. Euh le
le il y a encore 5 ans, on disait le
populisme quand même. En gros, c'était
réservé à l'extrême droite. En gros,
c'était ça. C'était tous les mouvements
auxquels on prêtait des affaires comme
le racisme, des choses comme ça. Pas
forcément à tort d'ailleurs, hein. Je Et
donc, on se disqualifiait les mouvements
qui seraient de cette mouvance là sous
le nom de populisme. Bon et puis
nouveauté depuis 3 4 ans, on s'est mis à
dire la bourgeoisie s'est mise à dire
les populismes. Ah tiens, mais qu'est-ce
que ça veut dire ça les populismes ? Moi
dans un premier temps, j'ai pensé que ça
ça désignait le nombre de pays qui
étaiit plus ou moins gangrainés par
cette lèpre pour reprendre les termes de
Macron parce que il y avait de la
Hongrie, il y avait un peu de Tchéquie.
L'Italie ça a commencé à bouger dans ce
sens-là puis on avait nos petits
populismes nationaux, c'est-à-dire en
gros le Rassemblement national ou bon et
voilà à peu près cette cette clique là.
Et en fait non, c'était pas ça. Les
populises c'étaient Marine Le Pen et
Mélenchon. Ah tiens, l'accusation de
populisme concernait les gens de gauche
aussi. Donc ça ne valait plus du tout.
La première hypothèse, la première
définition un petit peu clean que
donnait la bourgeoisie de populisme à
savoir des mouvements qui jouent sur des
affects obscur comme le racisme ne
valait plus parce qu'on peut reprocher
beaucoup de choses aux insoumis, on peut
reprocher beaucoup de choses à Méanchon
mais alors absolument irréprochable sur
le racisme. Donc les populismes enfin
c'était vraiment définitivement tous les
mouvements qui ne sont pas dans l'ordre
libéral. Et puis euh par extension, moi
je pense ce que je dis aussi dans le
livre, il est évident que c'est pas pour
rien que l'insulte suprême pour la
bourgeoisie contienne peuple dedans. Est
un mot construit sur peuple.
Euh bon bah je pense que là il y a une
vieille une vieille détestation du
populaire qui s'exprime tout simplement
à travers le la haine du populisme ou le
refus du populisme. Fondamentalement,
il y a dans la bourgeoisie un dégoût
profond de tout ce qui émane du
populaire, des classes populaires de du
bas pub, de la plebe, des choses comme
ça. qu'on a très très bien vu depuis le
début de du mouvement des gilets jaunes
qui a fait vraiment qui a imposé une
sorte de visibilité du corps populaire.
Le corps populaire avec ses gueules,
avec son bagou, avec sa façon de parler
ou de mal parler ou de parler pas
exactement dans les clous de la parole
habituelle, pas du tout une parole
managériale par exemple. Euh oui oui, je
pense que fondamentalement euh moi c'est
ce qui m'a frappé en réfléchissant sur
la bourgeoisie, c'est à quel point elle
peut se donner des atours très
contemporains, un peu nouveau. Euh et en
même temps, il y a une invariance dans
la bourgeoisie. Et l'invariance de la
bourgeoisie, c'est je possède, donc je
veux conserver. Et puisque je veux
conserver, j'ai tout à fait peur de la
masse qui menace éventuellement mes
avoirs et la masse, ben c'est les
classes populaires. Donc pour un
bourgeois, fondamentalement, il a
comment dire chevillé au corps la peur
de la plebe. Le le le l'individu issu de
la classe populaire est toujours
quelqu'un de potentiellement menaçant
pour la bourgeoisie. Les foulards
rouges, c'est ça. C'est le mouvement euh
de la bourgeoisie en mode gilet jaune.
Ah ben ceux-là, ils nous ont un peu fait
rire quand même. Je veux dire, moi je
Ah oui oui, ils m'ont fait rire. Ouais.
Non parce que ça comme démonstration de
médiocrité, de mesquinerie,
de conformisme, un but de lui-même,
ça c'est vraiment le pire de la
bourgeoisie là là. On a eu dans cette
manif là ce jour-là, je veux pas moyen
un concentré de parce que dans la
bourgeoisie, vous avez les dominants, il
a les décideurs, les cadres, ceux qui
vraiment impriment le mouvement, les
grands patrons, les capitalistes,
les fondés de pouvoir du capitalisme,
ceux qui se succèdent dans les
gouvernements depuis x temps. Et puis
vous avez cette petite masse un peu
silencieuse qu'on appelait la petite
bourgeoisie d'ailleurs à une époque qui
qui va être un soutien indéfectible pour
pour tout ça pour les gens but dessus et
qui se retrouve dans une position tout à
fait inconfortable et et qui a pour moi
susciterait chez moi plus parfois de la
pitié à savoir qu'ils sont
ils veulent absolument se distinguer du
populaire
et en même temps ils ne seront jamais
assez bourgeois pour pouvoir aspirer à à
je dirais une une aisance bourgeois
Ils sont dans cet entre deux qui a
longtemps incarné sur les sur les sites
usines le petit chef hein le petit chef
qui était probablement humilié et
regardé avec beaucoup de condescendance
par le vrai chef et qui était détesté
par les ouvriers et les travailleurs du
coin
qui passait sa haine sur le petit
travailleur. C'est ça.
Voilà. Qui se vengeait de ses propres
frustrations à ne pas être un vrai chef
sur le le petit Je crois que là Oui. Les
comment les foulards rouges. Ouais.
C'est une c'est la continuité de ce
sociotype tout à fait pathétique.
L'anarchisme, ça ça te fait penser à
quoi ?
Est-ce que il y a pas d'anarchisme dans
les gilets jaunes ?
Oui, c'est ce que je je crois m'être
entendu dire ça dans une radio. Oui. Non
non, c'est pas un mouvement anarchiste
dans la mesure où il est en d'ailleurs,
je veux pas du tout faire de généralité
sur les géné jaunes. Je crois que c'est
évidemment très composite et on trouvera
plein d'éléments très disparates dedans.
Mais globalement, je pense que la
demande faite à l'État n'est pas un
geste anarchiste. L'anarchisme
fondamentalement à Torto raison
d'ailleurs considère que l'État
n'accorde rien et que d'ailleurs il faut
rien lui demander en fait. Il faut rien
lui demander. Il faut organiser soi-même
un certain nombre de choses de de de
collectifs
de sites sociaux autogérés de Zad
pourquoi pas et on s'organise. Bon c'est
ça quand même le paris anarchiste, hein.
C'est c'est le pari de la commune contre
l'État.
l'analyse du traitement médiatique,
l'analyse des éditorialistes,
leur capacité à employer certains mots.
Est-ce que ça te fait bondir
en tant qu'intellectuel ? Est-ce que ça
te ça te fait peur ?
Bon, moi il faut bien savoir que pour
des raisons diverses, je bondis peu
et qu'en fait les éditeurs, enfin je
crois que c'est aussi ça par exemple,
voilà, on parlait d'anarchisme, moi j'ai
appris ça par le punk. C'estàd que le
punk qui est quand même une espèce de
d'incarnation musicale de l'anarchisme,
c'est discutable ce que je viens de
dire, mais je pense que c'est pas si
faux.
C'est à travers le corp punk que j'ai
que j'ai compris ce que pouvait être
l'anarchisme et l'attitude la
protoattitude de l'anarchiste.
Et je pense que fondamentalement un
anarchiste n'est jamais en colère contre
le pouvoir parce que il n'en attend
rien. On est en colère que par rapport à
quelque chose dont on a attendu, quelque
chose quand on se sent floué, quand on
quand on est un un amant et conduit euh
parce qu'on a attendu de de cette jolie
jeune femme ou de ce joli jeune homme au
choix qu'il se passe quelque chose entre
nous. Donc on peut être très en colère
d'avoir été conduit. Euh je pense que
ces éditorialistes, il faut s'en moquer
d'abord. Ça c'est vraiment le premier
geste pour moi à narcopunk.
Euh c'est c'est vous êtes ridicule,
c'est pas vous êtes scandaleux, c'est
même pas vous êtes indigne, c'est même
pas vous faites du mal, même si ils sont
à peu près tout ça, c'est que d'abord
vous êtes ridicule les gars et que la
première chose que j'ai à dire à cette
clic, c'est j'ai vraiment pas envie
d'être comme vous et je vous plains
d'être ce que vous êtes parce que c'est
bien triste le métier que vous faites.
Il est il est d'abord triste. Alors
après, on peut repolitiser un peu la
chose et être un peu moins dans une punk
attitude et être un peu plus dans dans
des réflexes de citoyenneté un peu plus
sérieux.
Oui, ces gens-là font du mal. Ces
gens-là objectivement font du mal
puisque ils ont ils ont leur rond de
serviette sur tous les plateaux de télé
et qui répandent le poison de
l'idéologie hein. Et et je crois que ça
marche quoi. C'est que une une des
raisons de notre impuissance politique
générale
vient du fait que effectivement ces
gens-là ont insinué dans les cerveaux
tout un tas de choses. Mais je crois
qu'ils sont pas les seuls. Faut pas faut
pas négliger aussi le fait que dans le
dans l'intoxication générale, il faut
évidemment incriminer des individus des
certaines position par exemple un
éditorialiste de BFM. Bon voilà qui
serait un peu l'emblème de ça mais faut
pas oublier que des institutions aussi
nous intoxiquent he je veux dire je
pense que l'école nous intoxique. Nous
sommes tous des des multixiqués par 15
années d'école
qui à l'école on apprend quelle est la
chose qu'on apprend à coup sûr dans une
école c'est déjà la discipline et
l'asservissement et et la soumission
hein quand même. Donc d'une certaine
manière dans cette espèce de
de cartographie ou de carte des
générales des institutions toxiques,
Jean-Michel Apatti, on lui prête
beaucoup trop de pouvoir d'une certaine
manière. Donc il faut quand même pas
trop trop se tromper d'ennemis ou se
tromper de réflexion dans cette affaire.
Pour moi, les éditorialistes, c'est un
peu du folklore.
Du folklore journalistique. Tiens, en
parlant de folklore journalistique, je
fais une petite parenthèse. Est-ce que
tu as entendu parler de la Ligue du LOL
? Bah comment ne pas en entendre parler
hein parce que ça fait une semaine que
c'est en boucle partout. Cela dit ça me
parmi les trucs qui parfois sont comme
ça produisent une sorte de d'hystérie
virale euh il y en a qui vraiment
parfois suscitent chez moi un désintérêt
total. Celui-là m'intéresse quand même.
Ça m'intéresse à plus d'un titre parce
que je dirais que alors là dans le genre
je pense que les brig c'est c'est la
brigade du LOL ou comment s'appelle
déjà.
La ligue.
C'est intéressant qu'il soit appelé la
ligue hein. Bon ceux qui ont un peu de
notion d'histoire comprendront.
Ils ont pas de notion d'histoire, ils
ont dû s'appeler comme ça pour par
rapport à la Ligue des Gentleman.
C'est Ouais, c'est possible. Et en même
temps, peut-être qu'un inconscient a
opéré en eux une vie un vieux souvenir
de leur révision du bac où ils ont quand
même vu le défilé des ligue en 1934.
Bon, est-ce qu'il y a pas un inconscient
fascisant qui se traîne choses ? En tout
cas, ce qui me passionne dans cette
affaire, bon d'abord, ils sont quand
même exactement le sociotype que j'ai
essayé de décrire dans l'histoire de ta
bêtise. Donc merci les gars de de
fournir de l'illustration
en chaîne à ce à ce livre. Euh non, ce
qui est intéressant c'est que les types
œuvra œuvre œuvreront peut-être encore
dans dans un espace moral et idéologique
qui est quand même celui de
la petite morale humaniste sympatoche.
En fait, on pourrait appeler ça des
cools. Moi, je les appelle les cools. Le
cool est gay friendly. Le cool est
évidemment pour l'égalité homme-femme.
Le cool est super au taquet sur autant
de cause que je partage hein, je
m'empresse de le dire.
Euh
bon, ces gens-là, voilà, c'est des gens
un peu de quotidien, l'émission Dian
Bartes, quoi. Même si quoi qu'il y a des
types, il y a des anciens de cette
émission qui sont un peu dans l'affaire,
mais c'est intéressant. Hugo Clément,
Martin Von c'est rigolo, c'est très
rigolo. Donc voilà, ce sociotype là, le
leur fond de commerce, leur leur
obsession, leur ADN, c'est vraiment
en fait de délivrer des leçons de morale
au méchant aux méchants pas beau du
monde entier, au méchants pas cool.
Donald Trump, méchant pas cool. Je n'ai
pas beaucoup de sympathie pour Donald
Trump. Je m'en serais je m'empresse
aussi de le préciser, mais chez eux
méchant pas cool alors qu'Obama gentil
cool. Bon, ils sont ils sont un peu
là-dedans, ça je le détaille un peu dans
le bouquin. Euh et c'est ces gens-là
qu'on prend en flagrant des lit de
misogynie, homophobie, tout ça. Alors,
soit on dit on fait juste comme eux, on
fait de la morale, genre ah là, ils sont
méchants, c'est horrible ça. Soit on
essaie d'analyser le truc. Alors moi ça
me passionne
parce qu'il y a quelque chose ce qu'il
faut voir dans les leçons de morale
c'est qu'elles sont pénible
mais qu'elles sont fausses. Il y a
quelque chose de profondément faux dans
la morale. Quand vous n'avez qu'un
discours moral, vous occultez tout un
tas d'aspects du vivant. Lesquels
aspects du vivant que vous avez refoulé
par Moraline, c'est Nietzs qui parle de
moraline, et bien vont faire retour
comme tout ce qu'on refoule. Voilà,
comme ça avait fait retour chez Medclat.
Moi ça m'a un petit peu frappé il y
aurait un parallèle possible entre
l'affaire Medclat et et ses gens. C'est
pas pareil mais il y a une analogie. Bah
voilà ces gens qui ont fait comment leur
fond de commerce ou le leur cœur de
métier était la morale, était la
coulitude, bah forcément les affectent
pas cool. On ont macéré en eux et avait
besoin d'un exutoire et Twitter leur a
offert cet exutoire. Il faut toujours se
méfier. Je trouve c'est Nietzs qui dit à
peu près, je connais pas la phrase
exacte mais c'est il y a il y a rien de
plus mensongé qu'un homme indigné. Alors
on est un peu loin du sujet mais par
analogie je pense que c'est quand même
ça. Méfiez-vous toujours des gens non
pas qui ont des réflexes moraux parce
que il faut avoir des réflexes moraux et
nous en avons tous. Quand on dit que le
capitalisme détruit la planète et qu'on
le déplore, c'est un réflexe moral.
Donc il faut pas évacuer la morale. En
revanche, des gens dont le régime moral
ou le registre moral est est le registre
exclusif à l'exclusion de toute autre
forme de pensée et de saisie du monde.
Alors, il faut vraiment se méfier de ces
gens. On découvre toujours des drôles de
choses sur eux. Donc cette affaire là
m'a m'a bien intéressé à ce titre là.
J'ai pour habitude de poser de temps en
temps une question qui fait bondir tout
le monde, c'est "Je me fais l'avoquer du
diable".
Ouais. Est-ce que les gens sont devenus
trop cons ?
Ouais, ouais, je t'entends souvent poser
cette question et non, j'en partage pas
le libélé, ça me fait pas du tout
bondir.
Du temps de ma de ma vie de chanteur de
punk rock, j'avais écrit une chanson qui
s'appelait Où sont les cons ? Parce que
ça, il y avait beaucoup ça dans le
milieu alternatif contestataire. C'est
qu' on s'en prenait beaucoup. Ah mais
tant qu'il y aura des cons, les gens
sont tellement des cons, les spectateurs
de TF1 sont des cons parce qu'à l'époque
c'était ça. C'était le spectateur de TF1
qui était l'emblème du con. Et je je
j'aimais pas beaucoup cette rhtorique
parce que d'une part elle elle elle vous
situe de facto dans le camp des pascons
et c'est bon c'est un peu une
autoglorification un peu facile. Et puis
d'autre part je suis pas sûr que c'est à
la connerie exactement qu'on ait à faire
quoi. Je je Non non non, il faut il faut
quand même affiner un peu le trait.
C'est c'est je suis pas sûr que ce soit
la par exemple je crois pas que nos
gouvernants soient des cons. C'est leur
problème c'est pas la connerie. Parfois
des gens pensent que les gouvernants
actuels par exemple gouvernent mal parce
qu'ils se trompent mais ils se trompent
pas du tout. Macron fait exactement ce
qu'il a envie de faire, ce pourquoi il
est programmé, c'est-à-dire mener une
politique qu'on va bientôt pouvoir
appeler ultralibéral. euh il se il
s'égar pas, il y a pas d'égarement chez
lui. Euh donc je je préfère toujours moi
partir de quand même du postulat que euh
notamment les les sujets sociaux euh
font les choses euh enfin en tout cas
les les les acteurs politiques, on va
dire plutôt, font les choses en
connaissance de cause quoi. Et puis euh
et puis faut pas négliger aussi que je
crois que règne beaucoup le par exemple
pour dire les gens qui regardent
touchent pas à mon poste sont des cons.
Ça serait qui les cons en fait ? Ça
serait ce serait quoi maintenant les
cons ? Ils font quoi ? des gens qui
ils sont où en fait ? Je je repose la
question que je posais en 96.
Toi qui toi qui parle de con, ça serait
qui ? B
nous, on porte pas de jugement, on pose
juste la question. On voit le la
population continuer de d'avancer dans
une marche où ils se font broyer. C'est
de la passivité intellectuelle. C'est
quoi ? Moi, je préfère toujours essayer
de prendre les comment dire les
phénomènes sociaux comme des phénomènes
organiques et physiques.
Bon, qu'est-ce qui a construit notre
impuissance politique ou qu'est-ce qui a
construit effectivement
une une je vais pas dire une bêtise
politique mais disons une inéducation
politique ? Je préfère le dire comme ça.
C'estàd que pourquoi il n'y a-t-il pas
eu éducation politique ou émancipation
politique en tout cas d'individu à
individu ? Bon si sont dit bah parce que
les gens sont des cons mais la connerie
c'est un c'est un effet, c'est pas une
cause. Alors la cause c'est quoi ? Bah
je pense quand même que c'est
l'embadement général je crois. Est-ce
qu'on laisse vraiment le temps à un
jeune homme ou une jeune femme de 14 ans
de s'éduquer ou de s'émanciper ? Pour
l'instant, je mets les deux verbes en
parallèle alors que je je suis plutôt
enclin à les opposés d'habitude. Mais
disons de de s'émanciper. Non, on est on
est en permanence pris dans des emplois
du temps. Euh je c'est pas rien l'école
quand même qui nous nous dépossède de de
milliers d'heures. Alors, il paraît
qu'on y apprend des choses. Bah, il
semblerait que non, puisque vous voyez
le résultat hein. En tout cas,
presque je dirais 100 % des Bacheliers
sortent avec une éducation politique
proche du zéro. Et quand des Bacheliers,
des gens de 18 ans ont une éducation
politique, une formation politique,
c'est-à-dire un certain nombre de
repères politiques où
ont contracté l'habitude de penser
politiquement les choses, c'est parce
qu'ils l'ont appris en dehors de
l'école. Alors ça s'est fait comment ?
Bah par rencontre, par conditionnement
familial aussi parfois. Moi, ça a été
mon cas.
Euh mais c'est pas parce que certains
étaient cons et d'autres pas cons.
C'està-dire qu'il y a il y a des
phénomènes sociaux qui font que se
construit une sorte effectivement de je
dirais pas de bêtises politique mais en
tout cas de oui d'inculture politique ou
de
non habitude de penser politiquement les
phénomènes.
C'est quoi la politique ?
Alors, en général, les gens à la télé,
ils disent "Ouais, c'est Ouais, c'est
c'est l'art de la cité parce que police
euh comme disaient les Grecs." Bon,
alors je vais essayer d'être un tout
petit peu moins euh comment dire
routinier, non ? Euh
en tout cas, je sais où sont les gestes
fondamentaux de la politique. Les gestes
fondamentaux de la politique c'est
"J'habite une cité, je j'ai un problème
dans cette cité. quelque chose
disfonctionne, quelque chose ne va pas
ou en tout cas il y a un écart ou un
yatus entre mon désir et l'existant et
donc je fais valoir ce yatus. Je le fais
valoir auprès d'autres citoyens habitant
la même cité. Peut-être queeux aussi
auront unatus mais qui sera pas
exactement le même que le mien. Donc
nous en discutons, nous délibérons et
peut-être que de cette délibération
ressortira une décision. Et ben c'est ça
l'acte politique. Alors après ça peut
mener euh si j'obtiens pas gain de cause
peut-être que je peux me donner des
moyens un peu plus brutaux, un peu plus
violents. Ça ça dépend des époques et ça
dépend de l'adversité. Mais je crois que
c'est fondamentalement ça. C'est il y a
du dissensus comme dirait Rancière hein.
Nous ne sommes pas tous d'accord sur la
façon d'habiter la cité donc nous en
discutons. Et si ma fois il apparaît que
nos intérêts ou nos désirs ou nos
opinions sont incompatibles, et bien ça
se jouera dans un peu plus de
conflictualité. Si je te dis la violence
et la force des faibles et comence où
s'arrêtent les connaissances.
Ouais, je je t'ai déjà entendu dire ça
vu que je suis ton ton premier fan et
donc je connais tout tes je connais tout
tout tes toutes tes pensées.
Bingo, il y a un bingo sur internet.
Moi faudrait lancer un quiz un jour
Furew, tu vois et je suis candidat.
Enfin, je
la fonction exponentielle raconte. Non
non, la violence et la force des
faibles. Écoute, c'est moi je je n'ai je
ne suis ni pour ni contre cette phrase,
simplement je me tiens à distance de ce
genre d'énoncé. à cause de leur
généralité parce que est-ce que tu
dirais que la violence qu'on exercé
récemment les gilets jaunes dans la rue
est la force des faibles ? Je suis pas
sûr. Peut-être qu'on pourrait dire que
d'avoir recours à une violence aussi je
dirais aussi peu organisée, aussi mal
articulée
est le symptôme du fait que décidément
le rapport de force n'est pas en leur
faveur. Ça ça je pourrais plutôt le dire
de cette façon-là. Quand on a recours à
ce genre de viandence là finalement
assez symbolico-folklorique
et euh Oh barbare ça je sais pas moi
j'ai rien vu de très barbare dans les
mouvements des gilets jaunes he
oui oui oui quand les mecs ils enfoncent
une porte de ministère moi moi je suis
je suis assez d'accord avec Cran Branco.
Pour moi c'est quand même le geste
politique de l'année quoi. Donc non non
non il y a rien de barbare dans tout ça.
En revanche, on peut dire que c'est
du point de vue du rapport de force
général, c'est quand même on est en
train d'engager un rapport de force avec
un ordre existant qui a pour lui la
police et l'armée. Il est évident que
ces gestes de violence sont dérisoires
anecdotiques. Je en revanche, ils font
peu ils font symptômes du fait que
précisément on a du mal à instituer un
rapport de force un peu plus conséquent.
Tuas tu as vu notre interview droit de
Branco ou pas ? Oui.
Bon, il avait quand même un prisme de
lecture très asséré et très prémonitoire
sur les les gilets jaunes.
Comment tu vois le l'avenir de notre
pays à court terme, moyen terme ?
Là, je suis pas très très bon en avenir.
Moi, je suis très très Je suis assez bon
en présent. Ça, c'est un truc que je
maîtrise assez bien. Le passé, pourquoi
pas ?
L'avenir,
tuanticipes quoi ?
Moi, je suis très à l'écoute, y compris
d'ailleurs ici de gens qui qui sont des
seuls qui peuvent qui sont à même de
nous donner des de faire de la pensée
prospective. C'est des gens qui
s'occupent d'énergie. Voilà, ça ça
m'intéresse et mais là-dessus, moi je
n'ai rien à dire. Je ne peux que me
mettre à l'écoute d'eux. Eux, ils ont
les moyens de dire des choses. Bon, euh
quant à moi, sur l'avenir proche
politique et sur les gilets jaunes, je
je sais pas quoi dire. Ce que je peux
constater, c'est que je pense quand même
que la il faut pas il faut il faut être
lucide, quoi. Euh,
il y a quand même pas beaucoup de gens
de gauche dans ce pays.
Voilà. Et je pense qu'il y en a jamais
eu aussi peu depuis l'après-gerre.
Euh donc
faute de combattant. En tout cas, le
combat n'aura pas lieu dans les mois à
venir, ça c'est sûr. Après bon,
peut-être qu'il y a des choses qui se
sèent et qui finiront par germer pour
reprendre une poésie que je déteste.
Mais voilà,
c'est quoi un mec de gauche ?
Voilà, c'est vrai que on est nombreux à
gauche maintenant à de plus en plus euh
préférer se passer de ce terme en fait,
je crois, auquel il faudrait qu'il
faudrait substituer auquel il faudrait
substituer plein d'autres choses. Moi,
je préfère dire que j'ai toujours un peu
pensé dans euh l'espace
euh anarcomarxiste. Enfin voilà, en
agitant d'ailleurs cette polarité qui
est très passionnante, hein. Si si vous
êtes si vous avez un cerveau, une partie
du cerveau qui est marxiste et une autre
partie du cerveau qui est plutôt
anarchiste, ça dialogue bien entre les
deux. Ça s'est souvent frité la gueule
entre les deux et les uns ont souvent
massacré les autres. Mais
intellectuellement et du point de vue de
l'analyse de des chiros de la situation
de la vie de la vie sociale, je pense
que ce sont deux traditions euh
extrêmement puissantes que je
redécouvre, que je découvre tout le
temps et porté par des figures tout à
fait admirables pour lesquelles je me
sens une grande fraternité. Donc oui,
bon, je crois que comment dire être de
gauche, bonfin
c'est considéré que allez on va le dire
les choses simplement,
c'est considéré que un le capitalisme
est fondamentalement destructeur
et que de qui est une petite conséquence
du 1, le capitalisme n'est pas
amendable.
Si vous considérez que le capitalisme
est amendable, bah écoutez, reformez le
Parti socialiste et puis amendez-le. et
puis perder et ridiculiser les classes
les classes populaires une nouvelle
fois. Euh bon, le capitalisme est pas
amendable. Alors, est-ce que pour autant
il est révolutionnable ? Est-ce qu'il
est dépassable ? Ça c'est une question.
En tout cas, ce dont je suis sûr, c'est
qu'il n'est pas amendable. Il est il
mènera à la destruction qui est contenue
dans son programme.
Si tu te retrouves dans une dans une
pièce avec Emmanuel Macron,
tu lui poserais quoi comme question ou
tu lui ferais quoi ? Ah, je sais très
bien ce que je lui poserai comme
question et d'ailleurs j'en meurs
d'envie. Oui.
Et j'ai bien envie de le cuisiner
là-dessus et de l'emmerder
et ça va te décevoir parce que c'est mes
c'est mes petites marottes à moi de
littéraire, hein. Mais une une des
choses qui m'a puissamment exaspéré dans
le fait Macron, c'est qu'il est c'est
qu'il a eu l'audace, l'outre cuidance et
l'obscénité en fait pour tout dire de se
prétendre littéraire. Alors ça non, ça
qu'il soit prétendu de gauche était
évidemment un immense mensonge. Mais
tout le monde était au courant. J'ai
l'impression que beaucoup plus de gens
ont cru quand même qu'il avait pour de
vrai lu des livres. Ça ça m'a un petit
peuouché en tant que gardien du temple
littéraire alors que je suis convaincu
que ce type a pas ouvert un livre de
littérature hein depuis 20 ans. Il en a
pas eu le temps. Bah je veux dire on a
pas le temps, hein. Euh et puis surtout
que ce qui apparaissait très bien
d'ailleurs dans un livre sur lequel
j'avais écrit dans Transfuge qui était
le livre de Philippe Besson qui avait
donc qui depuis est devenu conçu la Los
Angeles. C'était un des types qui
l'avait accompagné. C'est un écrivain
Philippe Besson que je connais
d'ailleurs en tant qu'écrivain qui a été
proche de Macron et qui a donc fait ce
livre qui est en gros une espèce
d'agographie de Macron où il racontait
la la campagne de Macron avec une espèce
de d'admiration comme ça pour le panache
du jeune homme qui conquérait comme ça
Paris tel un héros baljacien évidemment
et ce qui apparaissait d'ailleurs au
grand désespoir de Philippe Besson qui
lui a des goûts littéraires plutôt
portés sur une certaine modernité c'est
plutôt un fan de durass ou des choses
comme ça. Il désespérait de constater
qu'en fait Macron avait une culture
extrêmement archaïque et ringar dans
littérature et qu'en fait elle s'était
constitué sa culture. Bon, je veux dire
comme nous tous, comme disons la culture
littéraire de base de tout le monde, à
savoir le bac de français quoi quand on
étudie un texte de Standal et voilà, il
s'était arrêté au 19e en gros quoi.
Donc oui, si si je si j'avais la chance,
le bonheur de d'avoir Macron sous la
main, je lui disais "Manu, je dirais
Manu, tu as lu quoi là ces ces 15
dernières années ? Pour de vrai, hein,
pas pour de faux." Et puis s'il me
répond à un titre, et ben je lui dirai
"Vas-y, fais-moi le résumé et
parlement-moi". Quoi ?
Quand quand Emmanuel Macron parle
d'irénisme,
ça te fait penser à quoi ?
Il a parlé d'irénisme à propos de quoi ?
J'ai un trou de mémoire là.
Ouais.
De toute façon, iréniste, irénisme
irénique c'est quelque chose que
quiessuit beaucoup les loulous de
Montgen qui prétendent que peut-être un
jour on pourrait dépasser la propriété
privée.
Donc bon, moi je l'ai entendu peut-être
pas au collège lycée parce que là le mot
était pas à la mode à l'époque mais
c'est quelque chose qu'on qu'on entend
qu'on c'est un reproche qui essuit
beaucoup les gens qui ne se contentent
pas de l'existant. Donc oui oui bon je
pense que lui en tant que Alena et
ailleurs, je pense que ça devait être le
mot favori de ses compagnons pour
désigner tout ce qui était à gauche
d'eux en fait quoi dès que dès que vous
alors que c'est fondamentalement ce
qu'il faut bien affirmer aussi c'est que
les utopistes c'est eux hein. Moi je
pense que les les utopistes les plus
grands utopistes du moment et qui se
trouvaient aussi par ailleurs les plus
nuisibles des utopistes sont les
libéraux. C'est quand même des gens qui
considèrent que vraiment en continuant à
marchandiser à peu près l'ensemble de la
planète, on va on va s'en sortir quoi.
C'est eux les utopistes hein. C'est
c'est eux qui croient que par une espèce
de magie d'autorégulation du marché euh
la la la prélation générale va mener à
une espèce de va s'équilibrer, va mener
à une espèce d'assainissement de la
situation de tous. Bon, c'est où les
utopistes ? Moi, je pense que il faut
nous qu'on revendique absolument et ça
Rupin est très bon pour ça. Notre truc à
nous à la gauche radicale pour parler
que en ces termes-là, c'est le réel.
C'est là qu'on est fort. Où Marx est
très fort, c'est sur le réel. C'est pas
la puissance utopique de ce que Marx a
activé parce que des utopies, il y en a
il y en a eu plein. Je Mais je pense que
notre valeur ajoutée intellectuelle et
analytique c'est la
la puissance de captation du réel que
représente cette tradition de pensée.
On va je vais te poser une question qui
va essayer de te déconcentrer un peu.
Euh la géopolitique pas quoi ? Bah à peu
près rien. Donc c'est pour ça que je
regarde cette chaîne. Euh après ça me
passionne hein évidemment parce que là
euh penser les choses en termees
géopolitique me paraît toujours les
penser dans des bons termes plutôt que
de se raconter des histoires à la con.
Donc de savoir que le le je suis pas sûr
hélas que qu'on ait contracté ce genre
de réflexe à l'école ou ailleurs, mais
de prendre la question syrienne ou le
bordel syrien par le bout du gaz et du
pétrole me paraît toujours une façon
beaucoup plus pertinente que de le
prendre par les oppositions culturelles,
religieuses ou autres qui ne sont jamais
que une espèce d'habillage des
phénomènes géop géopolitique ou
géoéconomique. Voilà, donc je suis pas
extrêmement documenté mais dès que je
peux, je me documente là-dessus puisque
pour moi, c'est le bon bout.
Si tu te retrouves dans une pièce avec
Sarkozy,
toi tu veux absolument me mettre dans
une pièce avec des bléau en fait. C'est
ça ton C'est ça ton fantasme.
Non, Sarkozi, ça moi du temps où mes
amis étaient en boucle sur Sarkozy, moi
j'ai jamais été obsédé par lui en fait.
Je c'était pas quelqu'un qui m'énervait
plus que les autres.
Je vais même te dire un truc. Il m'est
arrivé parfois non pas de le défendre
mais de le dédouiner un minimum parce
que je trouvais qu'il y avait du popu
chez lui un peu. Mais du vrai popu hein,
pas du faux popu pour faire.
Ouais c'estàd qu'au moment de Casto
Pauvrecon par exemple moi j'ai eu des
milliers d'heures de débats devant des
bières pour dire que mais moi ça me va
si un président il dit ça. Moi c'est le
contraire que j'aime pas. Pourquoi
est-ce que les présidents parleraient
différemment de nous ? Enfin, moi je
suis très très démocratico
anarchico horizontal là-dessus. Le mec
moi en plus je comprends très bien sur
le moment. Il y a un mec qui se poste
exactement sur la route de SarkoZi pour
lui dire à quel point il veut pas lui
serrer la main. Le mec a le droit de
faire ça hein. Euh je trouve que c'est
de bonne guerre et que c'est un rapport
égalitaire que que Sarkozy dit "Bah
écoute, casse-toi pauvre con si tu veux
me serrer la main, tu es capable."
Ouais, moi qui suis Ouais. Moi je suis
pour que les présidents se comportent.
Alors là, moi je sais que c'est c'est
pas une thèse consensuelle et
majoritaire celle que je suis en train
de délivrer. Mais moi je Oui, moi je je
suppose qu'il se comporte comme les
autres quoi.
On a vu que tu t'étais un peu chauffé
avec Patrick Cohen sur la 5.
Euh tu as un mot à rajouter dessus. Tu
attendais c'est des nouveaux chiens de
garde ? C'est quoi
alors qu'il soit des nouveaux chiens de
garde ? Oui. Et je pense qu' un
documentaire du même nom l'a très bien
démontré et d'autres documents. Voilà.
Euh je savais que j'allais en fait mon
livre est très particulier celui qui
sort parce que
parce qu'il se trouve qu'il il décrit
par le menu un certain type social qui
est absolument coïncident aux gens qui
sont amenés à m'inviter sur les plateaux
de télé ou à la radio ou qui sont amenés
à être les premiers lecteurs de ce
livre, c'est-à-dire les journalistes,
ceux qui l'ont reçu il y a 2 mois avant
qu'ils sortent.
Je je pense pas que ce soit inédit dans
l'histoire des livres, mais quand même
là, il y a il y a une drôle de
conjonction, je dirais, entre le contenu
de mon livre et les situations que je
suis amené à vivre, les situations
audiovisuelles que je suis amené à vivre
pour le défendre.
Sizigie.
Oui,
si qui veut dire
Ah ben non, tu l'expliques toi.
L'alignement des planètes.
Voilà. Je sais pas pourquoi cette
expression alignement des planètes et ça
fait 2 ans que
tout le monde l'utilise et si je dis,
c'est encore plus raffiné.
Euh
donc je savais très bien que et
Anne-Élisabeth Lemoine, comment dire,
j'aurais pu construire mon livre autour
d'elle. Bon euh
alors je savais que je savais qu'il
était possible que Patrick Cohen soit en
plateau parce qu'il est pas toujours et
mais très vite en rentrant sur le
plateau, je me rends compte tout ça
c'est ça va paraître chichit ce que je
dis mais je pense c'est intéressant
comme ça techniquement je me rends
compte qu'il a pas de livre devant lui
et que donc c'est pas lui qui est chargé
de m'interviewer donc je me dis c'est
plutôt je vais avoir affaire à à
Ellisabeth Lemoine et à Marion Rery puis
éventuellement l'escur que je connais un
peu. Et donc je me dis OK très bien
Cohen a fait l'impasse sur le lit, c'est
pas grave, les mecs se se répartissent
le boulot. En fait lui il était sur
Philippe Val la veille, lui j'avais vu
l'émission la veille. Bon et très bien.
Alors ce qui m'a quand même un peu
énervé du coup c'est qu'il se quand même
qu' se permett d'intervenir malgré ça
parce que pour moi le deal c'est simple
he moi je fais un livre, tu m'invites
pour un livre, tu le lis, tu le lis puis
on en parle puis tu as le droit de pas
être d'accord. OK. Euh mais le mec qui
fait son petit sniper à deux balles là
et qui essaie de me chercher là tr 4 c
fois sur des petits trucs mesquins en
plus. Euh bon euh non vraiment pas. Donc
là ça m'a pas mis de bonne humeur et euh
et du coup je l'ai remembarré. Bon je
dois bien avouer que je suis pas à la
base un fan de Patrick Cohen. Euh je
pense que c'est quelqu'un qui a produit
aussi énormément de propagande quand il
était à la matinale de France Interre.
Euh il est pour euh il est un des pions
du glissement réactionnaire du Parti
socialiste, du glissement autoritaire.
Bon, en gros, c'est un valcien
fanatique.
Tiens, tu parles de Vals. Quand on voit
Vals, s'altrite en Espagne. C'est beau.
Bah surtout, c'est pas surprenant. Il
continue son programme. Tout est tout
est normal.
Vous savez, c'est comme c'est un petit
peu comme les mecs de la de la Ligue du
LOL quand vous voyez Vals, quand vous le
voyez à l'époque
déployer tant d'énergie et de Sur, je me
souviens dans un congrès à La Rochelle
contre le FN,
ce zèle qu'il mettait, ce zèle
antifasciste qu'il mettait sentait pas
bon, sentait, il faut toujours s'amener
de ce que j'appelle la psychologie
paradoxale. Quand vous voyez un tel
déchaînement d'énergie de quelqu'un pour
vraiment faire barrage au fascisme qui
vient, c'est bien qu'il y a des petites
particules fascistes qui sont en train
de s'agiter dans dans le petit bonhomme
sensément anti-fasciste qui est en train
de s'agiter là. Et euh on voit bien Vals
de toute façon, il a presque, je dirais
presque un il a un corps autoritaire, il
a un corps de petit caporal et donc
Ouais. Ouais. Aucune surprise à le voir.
Bah d'abord, aucune surprise à le voir
pour le coup officiellement
prendre l'étiquette d'un parti de centre
droit voire d'un parti libéral he
d'abord dans un premier temps en
Catalogne
puis effectivement par réglissement
accepter l'alliance avec l'extrême
droite
on va prendre deux trois petites
questions internet et revenir à notre
interview. Alors juste, j'ai fait une
bourde. Les nouveaux chiens de garde,
c'est pas Pierre Carl absolument.
C'est Gill Balbastre et Yannick Kgoat.
Voilà. Absolument.
Donc autant pour moi. Merci la
communauté. Donc question d'internet.
Que penses-tu des Black Block ?
Alors, je pourrais dire adhésion
esthétique, c'est sûr.
Adhésion esthétique. Et je crois que
parmi eux, je
je pourrais avoir plein de copains si on
se retrouvait à discuter. Je pense qu' à
mon avis, ils doivent avoir un certain
on doit avoir beaucoup de repères en
commun.
Que pensez après des black comme
puissance politique, comme force
politique ? Est-ce que c'est la bonne
méthode ? parce que c'est pas la bonne
méthode, j'aurais presque envie de dire
que j'ai pas d'opinion sur la question.
Alors, extrait du livre, tu tiens
l'élection pour le lieu exclusif de la
politique. Je tiens alors je tiens que
la politique a lieu partout, sauf là.
Explique-nous ça un peu.
Bon bah, le vote, le vote c'est le
contraire de la politique tout
simplement. Alors Schward dit un truc
bien, il il distingue bien le vote et
l'élection.
Il a raison, hein. Et et à ce, il sauve
le vote parce que quand je vote, au
moins, je vote pour une décision. Je
vote, bon ben je vais voter pour enfin
en tout cas c'est possible. Il y a il
peut y avoir une certaine négociation du
vote qui fasse que bah je vote par
exemple pour euh
abolir la propriété. Je vais dire ça euh
l'élection bah j'ai lit des personnes et
en plus l'élection he c'est quand même
intéressant que le le terme central de
notre système pseudo déémocratique soit
l'élection hein. C'estàd quand on élit
quelqu'un ça désigne des élus. Mais dans
une vieille rhtorique les élus sont ceux
qui se distinguent. Vous saz parce
qu'ils sont élus. Euh alors fut unint
temp ils étaient élus par providence
divine enfin tout cas par intervention
divine. Le doigt de Dieu se posait sur
l'élu. Euh bon maintenant on est
élucément par le peuple mais quand même
que ce soit le même terme est quand même
très très intéressant. Donc ça c'est un
procédé oligarchique aristocratique.
Donc ça c'est ça serait l'hypothèse Cho
que je partage. Mais fondamentalement ce
que Schir ne dit un peu moins que moi je
dis c'est que ce qui me frappe dans
l'acte même de voter c'est à quel point
il est disons physiquement et
gestuellement le contraire de des gestes
rudimentaires de la politique que je
décrivais tout à l'heure à savoir se
rassembler parler décider. se
rassembler, parler, décider, bah quand
je vote, je vote, je m'isole, je me mets
dans un isoloir, je ferme ma gueule.
D'ailleurs, ce qu'on dit pas aussi et
nos nos amis républicains antifascistes
là ne le disent pas, mais il faut bien
voir aussi que un acte aussi peu
engageant pour le corps, aussi peu
impliquant pour le corps et aussi peu
impliquant tout court hein, c'est-à-dire
que je vote en lousd, bon et ben
favorise tout à fait le fait que je
dépose des crottes dans dans l'enveloppe
hein, que je peux déposer des des
crottes racistes.
Donc eux qui sont tellement attachés à
leur petit système représentatif qui n'a
de nom enfin qui n'est démocratique que
par que par le le l'effet d'une
falsification euh devrait quand même
voir que oui, je pense que entre autres
dommages collatéraux, ce système là de
enfin cette ce protocole qui s'appelle
voter, mettre un truc dans une enveloppe
euh bah favorise l'accès au pouvoir des
partis fascistes.
élection européenne, tu en penses quoi ?
Bah, j'en pense que déjà je vais pas y
aller. Euh,
j'en pense qu'on est lié un parlement
alors qu'on sait très bien qu'il a aucun
pouvoir et que tout est dans la
commission. Laquelle commission, je
pense est en rapport avec d'autres
formes de puissance. Bon, donc bon, ceux
qui veulent participer à ce cirque
participeront. C'est bien dommage
puisque par ailleurs, on voit bien se
profiler
encore une fois le le plébiscite par le
vote
de deux parties pour lesquelles j'ai pas
beaucoup de sympathie à savoir. Le parti
libéral et le parti fasciste.
Le Brexit, le Frexit, le Italy exit, on
sort, on sort pas, on fait quoi ?
Je vois pas comment on peut euh
s'interroger sur le capitalisme et de ne
pas en passer à un moment à un autre par
l'interrogation quant à l'euro. Il reste
encore beaucoup de gens à gauche qui
refusent absolument de considérer cette
question par une espèce de de vieux
tropisme internationaliste que je
partage.
Mais je crois qu'ils oublient que
parfois il y a des luttes provisoires,
il y a des luttes contingentes, il y a
des enjeux, il y a des il y a des
sous-dialectiques dans la dialectique
fondamentale. Oui, fondamentalement,
nous sommes internationalistes. Il faut
pas lâcher là-dessus. euh mais de façon
un peu plus contingente, de façon il y a
il y a il y a des microluttes qui se qui
peuvent se passer et je crois
qu'effectivement la ligne de front
ouverte par la question de l'euro est
une est une ligne de front tout à fait
intéressante quoi. Mais ça c'était un
petit peu un débat euh Marx et Angel
sont sont beaucoup interrogés là-dessus
quand ils ont vu euh arriver les
premiers mouvements d'indépendance he
dans les pays colonisés. Donc était
embryonnaire à l'époque hein, c'était
des germes de mouvement indépendantistes
ou de mouvements donc nationalistes he
pour simplement obtenir une indépendance
nationale. Euh assez vite Marx Engels
qui ont un premier réflexe pour dire "Ah
bah il se trompe de cause. L'idée c'est
quand même pas une revindication d'avoir
un pays. L'idée c'est l'union de tous
les prolétaires. Et assez vite,
maintenant non, Marx et Engels écrivent
des textes assez d'ailleurs visionnaires
disant que ben non, on peut passer par
ces enjeux provisoires pour ensuite
arriver à des stratégies plus
internationales. Donc oui, je pense que
la ligne de front ouverte par la
question de l'euro et par le
souverainisme me paraît, il faut la
jouer.
Souverainisme ? Bah souverainisme, c'est
j'ai entendu euh Nataas Poloni ici même
il y a je sais plus quand je l'ai écouté
hier ou avant-hier en replay. Euh je
n'ai rien à ajouter à sa définition de
la souveraineté. Elle a tout à fait
raison de dire que la souveraineté c'est
la démocratie.
Je vois une parenthèse purement auto
pour nous on va dire. Vas-y.
Tu as vu notre émission avec Tanked
Ramonis sur l'archer ?
Oui bah évidemment mais moi j'avais vu
son doc avant.
Ouais ouais ouais. Super de cul.
Question internet. Quel mots ont le pire
usage possible dans les médias selon toi
?
Ah là là ! Mais alors là, c'est pas
possible ce que vous me demandez parce
que c'est tous les mots qui seraient à à
faire à corriger quoi.
Euh
bon, je pense j'en parle un peu dans mon
livre mais je pense que le terme
progressisme paraît alors là de niveau
niveau 9 dans l'entoureloupe, ça c'est
fort quand même. Euh et qu'on continue
donc il rejoue la même scène là quand
même en vue des européennes de nouveau.
Il joue la scène progressiste contre
populisme.
Bon et que les journalistes laissent
dire ça aux politiques, bon bah c'est
d'une inconséquence absolue quoi. Donc
celui-là je le mettrai quand même en un
actuellement mais il y en a tellement
d'autres.
Alors le bon mot à la place de populisme
c'est démagogue. Alors
ouais desmagogue oui pourquoi pas
démagogue ça ça avait un sens. Mais
alors dans ce cas-là des magogue est
complètement découplé de ce qu'on
appelle le populisme maintenant puisque
qui n'est pas des magogue parmi les
responsables politiques ? Enfin, je veux
dire, il faut toujours un peu en passer
par un peu de démagogie. Alors après, il
y a des degrés mais Non, non, mais vous
savez en plus ce que je dis pas sur le
populisme et qui est en fait
l'essentiel, c'est que le mot populisme
est construit sur peuple et j'ai dit à
quel point tout à l'heure bon du coup il
véhiculait une sorte de vieille haine du
populaire. Mais le mot peuple lui-même
est sujet à caution. Le mot peuple
lui-même est un mot, je dirais, de la
tradition d'extrême droite plutôt. Euh
je veux dire, moi dans ma tradition de
pensée euh
dans le le continent amical dans lequel
je circule, on dit pas peuple, on dit
les classes populaires, les classes
dominées, les classes inférieures, le
prolétariat, la classe ouvrière, la
classe des employés, la classe des
subordonnées. Tout ça est beaucoup plus
précis et beaucoup plus pertinent que
peuple. Alors là, moi je sais pas ce que
c'est que le peuple
si l'internet commun n'existe pas en
soi.
Ah pardon quoi ? Ah si l'intérêt désolé
si l'intérêt commun n'existe pas en soi,
comment on le construit ? Non non, tout
à l'heure, j'ai parlé d'intérêt général,
hein. Ou alors j'ai j'ai
eu un moment d'inattention par rapport à
ma propre langue. Euh et précisément, il
y a une autre notion que je préfère
d'ailleurs à à cette notion d'intérêt
général, bon encore une fois qui me pose
toujours un petit problème, c'est la
notion de commun qui est revenue un peu
en force aussi hein dans une certaine
certain champs intellectuel. La notion
de commun, ça c'est intéressant. Oui.
Qu'est-ce qu'on peut considérer qui
appartiennent au communé
donnée ? Euh Ah oui, là ça m'intéresse
parce que c'est plus concret. Alors
est-ce qu'on considère par exemple que
la santé c'est le commun ? Et si la
santé c'est le commun, elle doit
absolument pas être marchandisée. Point.
Bon ça c'est des horizons clairs hein.
Et puis et puis commun, c'est commune.
Bon tout ça tout ça m'intéresse. Là ça
commence à devenir vraiment intéressant.
La violence des riches comme l'ont nommé
les pinceaux Charlot mènent à la
destruction de la planète. On fait quoi
? Oui. Alors moi, j'ai je dirais par
rapport au pince charlot pour lesquels
j'ai évidemment plutôt de l'amitié et
même beaucoup d'amitié.
D'ailleurs, ce on va les recevoir dans
pas longtemps.
Et ben vous les saluerez de ma part avec
respect et fraternité. Mais non, moi
j'aime pas dire les riches. C'est un
truc que j'aime pas chez Étienne aussi.
Floire euh évidemment il y a des riches,
hein. OK,
c'est pas les riches, [__] C'est le
capital les gars, c'est pas pareil. Et
donc c'est la violence du capital hein,
dont dont je parle. Il y a même une
notion que l'ordon a repris récemment,
reprise récemment, mais qui est pas de
lui, qui est le capital au scène plutôt
que l'anthropocène.
Ouais. C'est pas l'être humain qui
détruit la planète ou qui se détruit
lui-même plutôt ou qui détruit les
bêtes. C'est pas l'être humain. Il y a
pas de natur, il y a pas
d'essentialisation de l'humain à voir
là-dedans, c'est le capital. Alors
après, peut-être qu'on est nombreux à
activer à notre échelle le capital en
consommant. Voilà, on est tous plus ou
moins dans mouillés dans le truc, hein.
Mais c'est le capital le la prédation.
Donc c'est la c'est la violence du
capital qui est une violence
inexinguire, irréversible. Tant qu'on n
pas arrêté ce bolide lancé comme ça sans
conducteur.
Euh bon, il accomplira la destruction
qu'il est voué à accomplir.
Alors pourquoi le bourgeois qui gagne
2500 € est plus proche de ceux qui
gagnent 15000 € que ceux qui ne gagnent
1500 ? Ben ça c'est oui ben je pense que
beaucoup voilà mon livre moi ne parle
pas des riches ni des ultra riches mais
parle vraiment de la bourgeoisie et la
bourgeoisie c'est large en fait hein
c'est pas mal de gens c'est 15 20 % de
la population peut-être un peu moin et
parmi lesquels effectivement il y a des
gens qui pourraient presque strict
sensus du point de vue de leur compte en
banque ou de leur patrimoine
être plutôt du côté des classes
inférieur mais pour tout un tas de
raisons parce qu'ils se vivent comme
ascensionnel parce qu'ils considèrent
que le mode de vie bourgeois est est un
modèle est un but à atteindre vont
plutôt pactiser objectivement avec la
bourgeoisie Donc oui, vous avez eu un
vote Macron. Il y a eu des gens qui
votent qui qui touchent 2000 balles et
qui ont voté Macron parce qu'ils
considérait que parce qu'ils adhèrent à
cette espèce comme ça de
start-up nation. Enfin voilà, tout ce
qu'on sait. Euh ils adhèrent au à à la
coulitude macronienne ou à la pseudo
coulitude macronienne parce qu'on voit
bien ce que donne la coulitude de Macron
quand il est un peu contesté hein. C'est
une coulitude qui se c'est que le jeune
coule se transforme assez vite en
adjudant chef quand même hein. Euh
donc oui, c'est c'est toujours troublant
de voir qu'il y a tout un tas de gens
mais c'est eux que je je vise entre
guillemets dans dans mon bouquin quoi.
Comment comment pouvez-vous être les
complices objectifs de
d'argentiers qui qui qui d'ailleurs non
n'ont pour vous que du méprise ? Est-ce
qui nous ramènerait à nos foulards
rouges ?
Euh hop ! Es-tu alors question
d'internet, es-tu inquiet
dans la vie en général ?
Ah bon, c'est pas précisé.
Alors, j'avais j'avais une réponse
d'hypocaneux à ça quand j'étais jeune et
femeur.
Je répondais toujours oui, je suis un
qui est au sens de un tranquille, au
sens où la quiétude, voyez là. Ou alors
je suis à type assez je suis un type
assez intranquille, ça c'est sûr. J'aime
bien le mot intranquille en plus c'est
très beau mot. Donc po a fait un beau
livre. Bon
deux livres même, je crois.
Ouais, moi je suis pas le mec le plus
tranquille du monde mais je pense que la
question portait plutôt sur est-ce que
je suis inquiet pour le monde, pour la
planète, pour mes semblables ?
Je crois que j'ai quand même des
capacités d'altruisme limitées, hein. Je
je
ne porte pas en permanence sur mes
épaules le sort du monde. Je je j'ai du
mal à euh compatir organiquement et
physiquement
aux petits ouvriers chinois qui sont en
train de s'activer pour que moi je
puisse consommer tranquillement. Si
alors ça c'est une question perso. Si je
te dis àal, ça te fait penser à quoi à
l'égal ?
À légal. Ah
c'est pas illégal, c'est àégal. Ah c'est
pas mal ça. Ça me plaît de toute façon.
Le A me plaît toujours comme préfixe
privatif ou préfixe ne, je sais pas
comment on dit. J'aime bien ça. Moi,
j'aime bien les gens amoraux et non pas
imorau. Donc à légal, c'est pas mal.
Ouais, c'est pas mal. Ouais. Ouais.
Qu'est-ce que tu entends précisément par
là ? B par rapport à toutes les les
dispositions et les directives qui nous
sont passées récemment sur internet
quand par rapport à la vie privée, ça on
revient, on fera une émission autour de
ça.
D'accord. Alors, question littéraire
d'Internet. Quel romancier vous plaise ?
Ça fait plaisir de parler un peu de
littérature, mais je vais je vais être
court pour pas ennuyer ceux qui euh il y
en a plein qui me plaît, je sais pas,
mais je peux
je vais en citer trois contemporains euh
parce que j'aime bien soutenir un peu
mes petits copains. Esnose
euh euh
Schnose Philippe Vasc, j'aime beaucoup
qui écrit chez Fillard et puis il y en a
tellement je pourrais citer Quintane,
Nathalie Quintane aussi, elle est pas
romancière c'est et puis sinon dans la
tradition B, je suis assez banal hein.
Moi j'aime Kafka, Dostoyevski, Faukner,
les romans de Bequette beaucoup et puis
puis le roman du 19e aussi. C'est je
partage ça avec Emmanuel notre
président. Je suis un je suis un grand
lecteur de Flobert et compagnie.
Est-ce que tu veux qu'on aborde un sujet
en particulier ?
Un sujet en particulier ? Écoute, non là
ça me vient pas directement.
Euh
non, je sais pas, j'ai plein de sujets
sur lequels je pourrais avoir mon mot à
dire mais non, ça me vient pas.
Alors, deux questions d'Internet. Si tu
fais beaucoup de plateaux télé,
qu'est-ce qui te garantit de ne pas
devenir un éditorialiste ? Et autre
question, comment on s'organise pour
penser contre soi-même ? Un conseil, une
méthode ?
Alors là, il y a vraiment deux questions
très différentes pour moi.
Bon, il faut savoir que moi j'ai par
rapport à la télé.
Il faut bien reposer les choses hein.
Moi, je
j'ai pas écrit des livres pour aller à
la télé. Moi
euh je vais parfois à la télé pour
défendre les livres que j'écris et
pour lesquels j'escomte un peu de
lecteur, ce qui est un peu la moindre
des choses pour un écrivain. Il a envie
d'être lu puis il a envie aussi de
péréniser sa situation économique. Donc
pour ça, il a besoin de vendre un peu.
Bon, donc là-dessus, bah ouais, bah il
fait un peu le truc d'aller à la télé
parler du livre, citer le titre. Parfois
c'est pas joyeux, parfois c'est vraiment
petit niveau intellectuel mais bon ça
fait partie du jeu. Donc faut quand même
pas se méprendre hein. En revanche, il y
a une époque, mais je le raconte aussi
dans le livre parce que je parle
beaucoup de moi dans le livre, dans
l'histoire de ta bêtise et j'essaie de
raconter comment finalement je j'aurais
pu un moment être appé par la
bourgeoisie et puis ça n'a pas eu lieu.
Alors j'essaie de m'expliquer à moi-même
comment se-il que j'ai pas été happé par
ça parce que à un moment j'ai pendant
deux ou 3 ans, j'ai fait des chroniques
à la télé. Je faisais une chronique
livre à la matinale de Canal et puis
j'ai fait euh j'ai participé à une
émission Le Cercle où je parlais de
cinéma. Euh bon mais alors moi dans mon
esprit euh il s'agissait quand même
parler de livres et de et de films quoi.
Donc il y a quand même il y avait loin
jusqu'à Christophe Barbier quand même
quoi. Je c'était pas encore ça. Et quand
on est invité à la télé comme je peux
l'être en ce moment à mon avis je vais
pas l'être beaucoup dans les semaines à
venir parce que parce que voilà passons
euh
fé avec eux.
Non mais je pense que bon clairement on
va pas me voir beaucoup dans les
semaines à venir dans sur le service
public. Je je comme là j'ai une petite
intuition comme quoi quand même ils se
protègent. Ils se protègent. Non pas que
je me considère comme dangereux he c'est
eux qu'ont peur de ma pauvre petite
personne inoffensive. Un rien un rien
les fait paniquer. Mais bon donc quand
j'y vais moi j'y vais en tant qu'invité
et je suis absolument pas mettre des
horloges. Je ne maîtrise rien dans le
dispositif. Les journalistes me posent
des les questions qu'ils veulent et en
général, c'est pas des questions que je
trouve extrêmement pertinentes. En tout
cas, elles ont elles ont rarement à voir
avec le travail pour lequel je suis là.
Euh donc, j'y vais vraiment pas guetté
de cœur et et en tout cas, je suis
absolument pas dans une position
d'éditorialiste. Donc on parle après
l'autre question, c'était quoi ? Je sais
plus.
Comment on s'organise pour penser contre
soi-même, un conseil, une méthode ?
Alors là-dessus, il faut être rigoureux.
Penser contre soi est un un comment dire
un cap qui me paraît
absolument nécessaire et réjouissant. Et
en même temps, je pense que c'est
impossible. Je pense qu'au bout du
compte, on ne pense jamais véritablement
contre soi. Par contre, on peut toujours
faire penser une partie de soi contre
une autre partie de soi. Et pour ça, il
faut s'armer de lucidité.
Je je dirais plutôt soyons lucide sur
nous-même. Alors, il y a un truc pour
lequel on peut être parfaitement lucide
sur soi parce qu'inversement des gens
vous opposeront toujours l'idée que mais
non, on n'est jamais le plus lucide sur
soi-même, hein, parce qu'on est toujours
on n'est jamais le mieux placé pour
s'évaluer soi-même.
Je veux bien commencer à considérer
cette question, mais il y a un truc pour
lequel on est toujours le mieux placé
par rapport à soi-même, c'est sur notre
vie factuelle. C'est-à-dire peut-être
que vous qui me regardez en ce moment
sur moi une vérité que moi je n'ai pas.
par exemple, quelle tête j'ai, quelle
euh quelle humeur ressort de moi, quelle
humeur ressort de mes gestes et cetera.
Ça c'est sûr, ça je n'en suis Vous êtes
beaucoup plus compétent que moi pour en
juger que moi-même. En revanche, il y a
un truc que moi je sais et que aucun de
nos millions de d'auditeurs ou de
spectateurs ne savent,
d'Uitrice
d'auditrices peut-être, c'est l'emploi
du temps exact de ma journée. Il y a que
moi qui sais. Et donc où je peux être
souverain par rapport à l'analyse de
moi, c'est sur les faits. Je connais les
faits de ma vie. Et alors là,
j'essaie de le faire un peu dans le
livre, mais je l'avais fait aussi dans
un autre livre qui s'appelle de singe ou
ma vie politique qui était une sorte
d'autoanalyse de ma de ma généalogie
politique, on pourrait dire. Ah bah
ouais, je crois qu'on a quand même du
matériel pour se juger soi-même, se
regarder. Moi, je il faut se regarder
faire. Euh mais
le geste introspectif est aussi
douloureux.
pas tout le monde est prêt à un instant
à avoir ce geste introspectif.
C'est très bien dit. C'est vrai que là,
j'en étais sur le le fait technique,
c'est comment arriver à être lucide sur
soi. Ben, je veux dire, se regarder
faire et s'éprouver dans une situation.
Par exemple, je je vais dire un truc qui
est un peu trop complaisant, mais je
c'est le premier exemple qui me vient en
tête. Je me suis vu en présence de la
bourgeoisie ne pas me sentir chez moi.
Ça disait des choses sur moi. En fait,
je me suis jamais découvert autant
anarchiste qu'en fréquentant un peu la
bourgeoisie culturelle. Je me suis vu
être irrité, je me suis vu m'ennuyer, je
me suis vu et cetera. C'est très
important. Après, ce que tu dis est très
est très vrai, c'est ça serait la
complication non pas technique de
l'auto-analyse mais la complication
psychologique. Et alors là, il faut être
simple.
Je ne suis capable d'une lucidité
cruelle contre moi et qui me coûte un
peu qu'à partir du moment où j'ai un
comment dire un stock de
d'autosatisfaction,
un réel stock de souffrance.
Mais les deux les deux en même temps, si
vous voulez par exemple, je peux je peux
très volontiers dans Histoire de ta
bêtise dire les parties bourgeoises de
moi dans la mesure où je suis assez sûr
d'être puissamment non bourgeois. Voyez,
euh je peux très facilement euh
reconnaître que j'ai raté un livre
parce que à tort ou à raison, hein,
peut-être que je m'illusionne mais
je suis intimement convaincu que j'en ai
écrit de bon. Bah peut-être que c'est
par mégalomanie, hein, je veux dire ça
vraiment. Mais là, on parle de phénomène
autopsychologique et donc je suis je
pense que j'ai une plus grande
proportion à l'autocritique
sèche et froide et cruelle. Il faut être
absolument cruel avec soi
si j'ai une un petit stock d'amour de
moi-même. C'est pour ça que c'est très
important de s'aimer. C'est c'est il
faut être il faut être content de sa
propre puissance aussi.
C'est c'est très voilà pour exercer très
très bien la pensée contre soi-même.
Christian Murti, ça te parle ?
Bah ça me parle parce que j'en entends
parler de plus en plus par toi sans
doute par quelques-uns de tes invités
mais j'ai jamais pratiqué
directement.
Alors si tu question internet, si tu
étais ministre de l'éducation nationale,
tu ferais quoi ? Ben,
j'avais écrit un texte là-dessus parce
queil y avait la revue Charles avait
demandé à des igoto de mon genre de il
nous avait désigné ministres les uns et
les autres et puis chacun avait écrit un
petit texte pour dire ce qu'il ferait
dans les premiers jours de sa mandature
ou je sais pas comment on dit pour un
ministre.
Et donc moi évidemment j'avais hérité de
l'éducation nationale puisque j'ai un
peu un passif dans le dans le domaine.
Et donc j'avais écrit un texte où je
décrétait ma première mesure en tant que
ministre d'éducation nationale qui était
évidemment de supprimer l'école et donc
c'était aussi une autoamputation du
ministère. Donc ça faisait deux gestes
anarchiste pour le prix d'un et donc
j'expliquais je j'ai grainais la raison
pour laquelle je supprimais en tout cas
l'école obligatoire.
Question d'internet. Qu'est-ce que tu
penses de la collapsologie ?
Alors
bon, je je n'en connais globalement que
Pablo Servigne. J'ai moins écouté les
autres mais c'est vrai queil est un peu
le leader sur le il a un peu breufteté
la colopsologie Pablo.
Non non rien bruffeté du tout.
Non non mais je l'aime bien par
ailleurs. J'ai plutôt beaucoup de
sympathie pour lui
et j'écoute avec attention tout ce qu'il
dit et notamment quand il est technique
et scientifique. Ça je vraiment j'aime
bien quand il repart de l'énergie par
exemple. Ça, il est passionnant sur ces
questionsl quand il fait un peu plus de
prospective moralo-politico
philosophique, là je le trouve un peu
plus nébuleux et je le trouve ambigu et
je le trouve pas assez politique par
exemple. je le trouve pas, je le trouve
un peu plus. Il a parfois des accents
qui m'évoquent davantage un
développement personnel raffiné et
subtile qu'une véritable pensée
politique. Euh mais je crois que lui il
se refuse aussi justement par pour tout
un tas de raisons, il refuse de
d'engager
une rhtorique sèche et agressive contre
le capitalisme. Donc alors que je pense
que c'est ça le fond de sa pensée.
C'est un mec qui est très très sympa
mais j'en doute pas une seconde. C'est
c'est vraiment d'une gentillesse
mais j'allais presque dire qu'il est
peut-être trop sympa comme une de ses
idoles Cropotkin qui se trouvait aussi
une de mes idoles et et Cropotkin dans
la grande tradition des anarchistes a
fini vaincu d'effet laminé parce que
quand même à force de s'être auto
persuadé lui-même en observant des
fourmis que au bout du compte les hommes
avaient une propension à la fraternité à
l'entraide dès que sa merde je
caricature évidemment Cropotkin et
Servin ça vaut mieux que ça bah que
quand ils sont pris tous les deux dans
la gueule enfin Cropotkin et un certain
nombre d'anarchistes la violence brutale
et cynique de la bourgeoisie, du
fascisme et parfois des marxistes et des
et des Staliniens. D'un seul coup, ils
sont rendu compte que la fourmie humaine
n'est peut-être pas aussi euh comment
dire
programmé à l'entraide.
Alors euh dernière question internet, je
m pas la dernière mais on va passer, on
va reprendre le fil de notre interview.
Michel Cloucar, tu connais ?
Ouais, c'est pareil. C'est marrant que
l'Oscar il a il a une nouvelle vogue,
une mais je me demande si ça passe pas
par Micha. Je crois que c'est Michale et
qui l'a qui l'a remédiatisé.
En fait, je je vais dire un truc qui par
quoi il faut toujours commencer quand on
vous demande ce que vous pensez d'un
intellectuel. Je n'ai jamais lu Michel
Cloucard. Je n'ai lu que des articles
sur lui. J'ai vu un ou deux passages
télé qu'il a pu faire à l'époque.
Alors, un moment, j'ai eu tendance à le
classer dans la dans la
dans l'étiquette gauche réac ou marxiste
réactionnaire.
Et plus ça va, plus je me dis et je
l'avais même un tout petit peu je
l'avais titillé dans un un livre de
d'entretien que j'avais fait.
Je pense que je serai moins sévère
maintenant avec lui parce que il est
quand même très passionnant ce monsieur
notamment sur la consommation. c'est si
vous voulez en en gros et je devrais pas
m'aventurer là-dedans mais je vais je
vais faire cours parce que encore une
fois je connais pas assez bien sa pensée
mais globalement ce que je percevais
chez lui c'était quelque chose qui que
j'ai perçu chez beaucoup de gens de
gauche qui ont glycéréac c'est qu'on
commence à incriminer la consommation et
on finit par incriminer les
consommateurs. Ce qui nous reviendrait à
notre à notre débat sur les cons.
Bon, c'est la consommation le problème,
c'est pas les consommateurs qui
s'épauvent con. Et puis en plus caron
est beaucoup pris à la culture de masse,
y compris bon par exemple au rock and
roll, au rock.
Et oui, OK, bien sûr que le rock a fait
partie d'une sorte de soft power
américain et qu'il a été une grande
entreprise commerciale, bien sûr. Est-ce
que pour autant je ne dois pas laisser
une petite porte ? Sinon, si c'est pas
le cas, moi toute ma vie se trouve nié,
hein. Mais une petite porte, c'est vrai.
Le type achète un un album de rock parce
que il est conditionné à l'acheter et
parce que il y a eu un marketing pour le
faire acheter. OK, très bien. Mais
après, le type se retrouve tout seul
dans sa chambre et il passe en boucle ce
cet album. Et il y a une chanson sur cet
album qu'il adore particulièrement, la
7. Voilà, sur un CD. Voilà. Et il y a un
moment, il y a 20 secondes dans cette
chanson qui lui provoque une jouissance
extraordinaire. dans cette chanson des
clashes comme moi quand j'avais 15 ans
ou dans cette chanson de Noé fix comme
moi hier dans ma chambre. Euh,
j'écoutais coquille de clown et a un
moment voilà, il y a un doublement de
guitare qui à chaque fois me rend
dingue. Cette dinguerie-là,
elle m'est venue par le marketing, par
le commerce, même pour un groupe punk
rock comme Nofix. Mais cette dinguerie
là, le système l'a pas l'aura pas. elle
est en excès par rapport au
système de production consommation dans
lequel j'ai été pris. Je trouve que
c'est ça que les penseurs comme Klouska
ont du mal à à c'est la petite nuance
qu'ils n'ont jamais
et il faut pas l'oublier. Je veux dire,
nous il y a il y a il y a des éléments
enfin comment dire il y a des effets
tordus du capitalisme qui fait que
parfois il y a eu des gestes
d'émancipation qui ont été portés par
des produits commerciaux de la même
façon que moi je pense que je
m'émancipais un peu quand je regardais
Colombo quand j'avais 16 ans sur TF1
quoi. Voyez ce que c'est c'est il faut
jamais confonde les deux. l'analyse
systémique de la consommation et
là-dessus je pense que je serais
absolument d'accord avec Cluscar et tout
un tas de gens et l'analyse
anthropologique de ce que font ces
produits aux gens et il faut pas prendre
les gens pour plus con qu'ils ne sont.
Propagande ça te fait penser à quoi ? Tu
mettrais tout de suite là comme ça si je
te dis propagande ça te fait penser quoi
? Emmanuel Macron, Vladimir Poutine,
Donald Trump, Kim Jung.
J'étais chez Tadei il y a pas longtemps.
Il a dit comme souvent Frédéric Tadei
quand même un des interviews les plus
intelligents qu'on a connu quand même.
Bon bref, il a dit un truc pas mal parce
qu'il était il invitait un type qui
venait de sortir un bouquin sur la
propagande et qui ciblait comme par
hasard en priorité Poutine, Trump et Kim
Jung ou des trucs comme ça. Et
et et Tadei qui qui a de la culture et
qui commence par ailleurs à avoir un peu
de bouteille disait "Mais mais en fait
le mot propagande dans les années 70
c'est un mot positif. euh les les
groupes gauchistes disaient qu'ils
faisaient de la propagande et
l'assumaient. Donc en fait la politique
c'est la propagande. La politique c'est
subjectivement j'ai des idées et et
j'essaie de déverser mes idées en tout
cas de les répandre de sorte que ça crée
des mouvements. Euh quiconque prétend
être objectif et neutre dans cette
affaire, c'est lui qui est un malade.
Donc le problème n'est pas tant qu'il y
ait de la propagande, le problème c'est
qu'elle ne disent pas son nom. Et ce qui
est bien au moins avec des gens comme
Poutine, c'estune certaine manière la
propagande russe, elle dit son nom. Bon,
ce qui est beaucoup plus retard quand
même, c'est quand la propagande ne dit
pas son nom et qu'elle se pique
d'objectivité gestionnaire ou
managériale.
Monsieur Macron,
non, Macron,
bah par exemple, évidemment, enfin je
tous ces gens qui dire il y a pas, c'est
la fameuse phrase de Tony Blair que
j'avais mis dans une pièce de théâtre.
Il y a pas de droite, il y a il y a pas
de gauche, il y a que les politiques qui
marchent, blabla blabla blabla. On va
s'asseoir autour d'une table et va y
avoir et tous ensemble on va étudier la
solution objective et scientifique du
problème et tout le nord-est que
subjectivité, fake news et propagande.
Il faut qu'il sachent ces gens que ils
sont subjectifs, ils ont une vision
très orientée du monde et ils ne cessent
d'en faire la propagande parfois malgré
eux et mais parfois en en connaissance
de cause.
Anuna chez Chiapa, du moins à Chiapa
chez Anuna.
Moi, j'ai pas regardé beaucoup. J'ai vu
que des extraits après.
Non, mais déjà moi je pense que déjà la
réponse est déjà contenue dans la
question. Che pas chez Hanouna. Bon, je
pense que
le le rire est intrinsèque.
Si tu devais nous poser une question,
c'est une question que vous a déjà posé
un un mec que j'aime beaucoup qui
s'appelle Schneiderman, que je trouve un
très grand journaliste et un très
qui fait un bon bouquin d'ailleurs.
Ouais. Que j'ai pas lu d'ailleurs, mais
que je l'ai entendu en parler trois
quatre fois.
notamment ici et ouais, il a commencé
par vous poser la question que n'importe
quel euh
mec conséquent, mec ou nana conséquent
qui passe ici devrait vous poser, c'est
quoi votre modèle économique ?
Alors là, on passe en mode pro. Euh on
paye tout le monde maintenant, compris y
compris moi.
On est entièrement financé par la
communauté.
On va payer 20 % de de taxes tout de
suite sur ce qu'on soit. Euh et on
essaie de on va essayer cette année de
faire fonctionner la chaîne YouTube sur
ce modèle-là, c'estàdire auto financé
par notre propre communauté. On va
essayer de continuer sans pub sans sans
ça. Euh qu'est-ce qu'on peut te dire
d'autre ?
Moi, j'aurais une autre question alors
parce que tu dis la communauté ce qui ce
qui suscite énormément de fascination
chez plein de gens. Je
les gens sur Tipi et les gens sur nos
réseaux sociaux. Mais non quand même, tu
vois bien. Ouais,
c'est sûr les ont un pouvoir d'achat
beaucoup plus important que les mains
partie des gens.
Ouais.
Ben c'est ça justement. Est-ce que tu
aurais le profil type de du membre de la
communauté ? C'estàd en gros
type
bah si il y en a toujours un, il y a
toujours une tendance lourde. C'est
comme si je te dis si je vais à Debout
en 2016, le profil type c'est un jeune
homme de 28 ans qui fait des études de
sociaux.
Le prof le profil type c'est
ingouvernable.
On dirait une réponse de politique. Oui.
Non mais là oui d'accord. Tu me fais le
profil psychologique type. Mais quel est
le profil sociologique type ? Il il y en
a pas. C'est sûr.
Bon si tu me le dis.
On s'est fait emmerder à l'école
peut-être. Non.
Ah c'est ça. Vous êtes des vous êtes des
enfants martyres.
Est-ce que tu écoutes Non, on est pas
martyr. Non. Est-ce que tu écoutes Kerry
James ? Question d'internet.
Non mais c'est un est une erreur je
crois et ça fait longtemps qu'on en
parle, on en parle beaucoup. J'ai lu
quelques-uns de ces textes parce qu'on
m'a souvent dit du bien de ces textes et
de fait ça m'a ça m'a pas déplu ces
textes mais j'écoute pas parce que ma
période d'attention protéap est derrière
moi quand même. J'ai j'en écoute plus
beaucoup.
Ça remonte à à combien de temps ton
dernier joint ? Ah là là, c'est vieux
parce que je Non non parce que j'ai
arrêté
[__] hyper tôt. Ah en 92, j'ai dit à
mes potes, j'avais 23 non 21 ans, j'ai
dit à mes amis, non moi je vais plus
faire ça, ça va C'est pas mon truc,
c'est mal.
Non, c'était pas la drogue. C'est mal.
Je pense que d'autres drogues
étaient beaucoup plus ajusté à moi. Mais
je sais pas mais j'ai j'ai assez peu
exploré ce domaine mais je pense que non
le cheat.
Je parle pas du cheat, je parle de
l'herbe.
Ouais, de l'herbe. Ouais. Non mais enfin
pour il y avait indifféremment l'un et
l'autre qui tournait à l'époque et non
c'était pas ma
ça c'est peut-être mon côté vendéin
indécrottable. Moi je suis quand même
resté le truc c'est la bière quoi.
Voilà.
Oh [__] les gars vous avez encore des
Ah ça c'est une très bonne question mec.
Pardon. Est-ce que tu as lu la trilogie
du comité invisible ? Oui, évidemment.
Je suis censé en dire quelque chose.
Et alors,
bon, d'abord les le mec qui écrit ça ou
les deux ou les trois, je sais pas, ou
les 10. Allez, on va faire semblant de
ou la nana
à une plume.
C'est trois livres,
je dirais presque de haute littérature
et c'est leur grande qualité, c'est leur
grand défaut parce que Coupa, puisqu'il
est dans le coup,
qui te dis ça ?
Euh,
a tendance à mimer un tout petit peu
trop son idole de bord. Voilà, ça c'est
pour le texte lui-même. Maintenant, ils
ont des analyses. Alors après, on peut
discuter des heures sur le contenu.
Je les trouve trop injuste et
trop euh routinièrement
euh hostile à la à des gens comme les
insoumis, tout ça. Je tr je trouve que
ces bisb là qui ont une profondeur,
elles sont plus d'actu enfin comment
dire, c'est pas la priorité quoi d'aller
d'aller emmerder les insoumis.
Euh mais en même temps, il y a des il y
a des microanalyses dans ces trois
livres qui sont absolument géniales,
notamment dans le second. Alors, c'était
à nos amis le second où je confonds. Il
y a demain qui est le 3è ou dans nos
amis, j'étais été impressionné par
quelques pages qui étaient des pages
analytiques hein quand ils analysent les
rapports de force, les quand ils
prennent une entrée d'ailleurs.
Bon, on peut être fier d'avoir ça dans
notre littérature intellectuelle
contemporaine.
Laurrection qui vient,
je crois que ça a été un bouquin hyper
important pour tout un tas de gens, mais
pas moi. Je pense ça été hyper important
pour des jeunes gens entre 18 et 25 ans
qui ont lu ce tru là autour de 2008 9.
Je sais plus quand c'était exactement.
C'était un peu avant parce que l'affaire
Tarnac c'est un peu avant.
Et je crois que ce livre a été
fondamental quoi enfin a à averé
beaucoup d'énergie militante et
contestateur. Donc à ce titre là c'est
respect.
Est-ce que tu as lu le crépuscule de Roi
de Branco ?
Oui.
Et alors ? Moi j'adore. Alors, si je
croisais Ran demain, on s'est
croisouillé il y a pas longtemps par
hasard, mais il faudrait qu'on qu'on
prenne un verre plus long ensemble.
Euh, je dirais d'abord que j'adore ce
bouquin, que c'est un bouquin nécessaire
et cetera et cetera. Euh, je pense que
c'est un bouquin qui est très largement
euh quand même euh euh embourbé de
l'intérieur par sa volonté stylistique.
Il a quand même voulu faire un peu de
grand style alors que je crois qu'il
tenait entre les mains un grand livre
factuel. des faits, des faits, des
faits, des noms, des voilà des réseaux
qui s'est tissaient très très bien. Bon
alors si on arrive à frayer son chemin à
travers cette cette boursoufflure
stylistique, c'est un peu injuste que je
dis mais voilà, c'est pour aller vite.
La nouvelle édition va être expurgée de
tout ça.
Bah c'est parfait. Alors là enfin, on
aura le grand livre qu'il avait entre
les mains parce que il est dans une
position géniale Ran, parce qu'il il a
vu des choses de l'intérieur et il les
ramène.
C'est un traître à sa classe. Enfin,
c'est ça ça produit toujours les
meilleurs ça.
On arrive à la fin. Euh
trois bouquins à conseiller
et un conseil pour les jeunes
générations.
Bon, alors les bouquins, je vais
peut-être je vais dire les promis qui me
viennent à comme ça. Comme ça, ça sera
en en pilote automatique. Je dirais les
carnets du sous-sol de Stoevski.
Euh Lumière doute de Fokner et euh allez
un français
euh
bon
attente de Dieu de Simon Veale qui est
un bouquin que j'ai découvert récemment
enfin il y a dizainza d'années qui qui
ne cesse pas de me de me hanter comme
diraient
les comédiens quand ils parlent du rôle
dont ils sortent.
Et un conseil aux jeunes génération,
c'est ça le truc hein.
Une bouteille à la mer, quelque chose
d'impérissable.
C'est ça. Ouais.
Alors, je vais je vais je vais un peu
faire chier d'abord.
Prends tout ton temps.
J'ai deux problèmes avec la question. Tu
as un conseil aux jeunes génération ?
C'est
c'est pas une question.
Ouais. Ouais. Enfin avec la l'invitation
à
euh
enfin, j'ai un deux problèmes avec cette
formulation. Premiè, c'est le conseil.
je un peu de mal à donner des conseils
et alors encore moins de je dirais de de
vieux à jeune ou d'adultes à moins
adulte. Euh
je ne crois pas à cette session.
J'aurais détesté, je détestais quand
j'avais 15 ans que les adultes se
prévalent
d'une expérience qui les fonde à me
donner des conseils. J'aimais pas ça. Et
moi maintenant que je suis passé du côté
adulte et que je me suis rendu compte de
l'intérieur qu'adulte ça n'existait pas,
que c'était une fiction, euh je vraiment
je déteste céder à mon tour à cette
fable et prendre mon neveu entre cas
Dieu dire c'est petit écoute tonton, je
me vois ne pas aimer ça.
Donc en fait, j'aimerais plutôt donner
faire part à des jeunes gens et à des
vieux du conseil que je me donne à
moi-même
tous les jours.
Tous les jours, la lutte quotidienne et
concrète he là cette fois on est dans
dans du concret, c'est une lutte pour le
temps. Et moi, j'ai perçu ça assez tôt
en fait intimement. J'ai été très très
vite conscient.
très très tôt dans ma vie, je pense
c'était un peu structuré autour d'une
certaine angoisse d'ailleurs, mais que
tout allait jouer sur le temps dans
cette affaire, qu'en fait les
l'émancipation, c'était d'abord
s'émanciper du temps imposé et c'était
arracher du temps à soi au temps
précadrié par la société.
Et c'est très concrètement à ça qu'on a
affaire en fait nous les individus.
C'est arracher du temps. On nous impose
des emplois du temps euh à l'école après
on arrive les études pareil un emploi du
temps et puis on arrive sur le monde du
travail et là on vous impose une grille
horaire et cetera. Enfin un emploi du
temps qui porte pas ce nom mais qui
et alors qu'est-ce qui vous reste comme
temps à vous quoi ? Bon ça ça était déjà
mon vrai problème quand j'avais 20 ans.
C'était comment est-ce que je vais
réussir à gagner ma vie en gardant mon
temps ?
Donc là, ça a été beaucoup de calcul de
ma part. Bon
parce que moi je voulais garder du temps
pour lire, pour écrire, pour regarder
les films, pour étudier de la musique,
pour boire des cours avec mes copains et
mes copines. Bon
pour la sérendipité,
c'est ça mot à la mode. Attention aussi
he celui-là hein hein. Il arrive en
force lui hein. Moi je l'ai appris il y
a 3 semaines donc ouais
avec frugalité. Non.
Ah non frugalité je ça va je possède ça
depuis longtemps. C'est rendipité. Ouais
c'est ça. C'est rendipité. Ouais.
Euh donc arracher du temps
et donc l'adversité à l'époque c'était
le monde du travail
et c'est toujours c'est toujours ça quel
temps je vais donner au capital en fait
hein celui qui me demande des heures de
travail en échange de quoi il me
rétribuera, il me rémunérera et en
échange de quoi je pourrais manger.
Alors la chose c'est quand même
compliquée depuis 15 ans hein parce
qu'avant quand on rentrait chez soi,
qu'enfin on pouvait rentrer chez soi, on
avait affaire à une adversité qui était
bah déjà il était quand même 19h donc
est-ce qu'il me restait du temps pour
moi ? Et deuxièmement, est-ce que
j'aurais l'énergie ? Est-ce que cette
saloperie de travail n'allait pas me
poursuivre jusque chez moi par la
fatigue ? Et ben ouais, en fait souvent
on rentre chez soi, on est crevé et du
coup on voulait lire un livre. Ben en
fait non, on va pas lire un livre, on va
on va regarder la télé, on va faire un
truc comme ça un peu plus passif.
Alors ça ça a été la grande difficulté
mais c'est ajouté à ça une autre
difficulté redoutable, c'est que le
capital et autres forces obscur m'ont
poursuivi jusque chez moi par
l'intermédiaire d'objets technologiques.
Alors ça c'est nouveau quand même.
J'arrive chez moi, je viens de quitter
mon patron ou mon N + 1 ou mon je sais
pas quoi.
J'arrive chez moi, merde, j'ai un
ordinateur quoi. il est connecté à tout
un tas de trucs, il y compris des choses
qui envoient de la publicité ou qui
requierent mon attention, hein, parce
que l'économie de l'attention, tout ça,
Stiglor, on a très bien parlé ici et
puis ailleurs.
Alors là, c'est la lutte qui commence là
et c'est une lutte physique. C'est une
lutte physique. Comment je peux
accorder l'attention que je veux à ce
que je veux et non pas me laisser capter
mon attention par tout un tas de choses
qui m' qui m'aimentent. Ça c'est très
concret ce que je dis hein. C'est pas
des vues de l'esprit, c'est pas euh et
moi c'est une lutte concrète que j'ai.
Alors moi je viens du 20e siècle donc
j'ai des armes pour ça. Je suis habitué
à ce que j'appelle le métabolisme de la
lecture
de l'attention longue portée à des
objets comme un film qui fait 1h 3/4 ou
à un livre de Kafka qui demande 12
heures de lecture. Je suis habitué mais
même moi je me vois parfois intoxiqué et
même moi je me vois parfois aimanté par
ces trucs-là. Donc je me dis que ça doit
être d'autant plus redoutable pour les
mecs qui viennent pas du 20e siècle
comme moi quoi. En tout cas qui viennent
pas du même siècle.
Or, c'est bien ça le truc quoi. Et que
alors là, je le conseille aux jeunes, à
moi-même, aux vieux, à tous hein, tous
ceux qui rentrent chez eux et qui fut
unintemps aurait sans doute consacré, se
serait concentré longuement sur un
texte, par exemple un texte
qui au lieu de quoi vont volatiliser
leur attention dans une espèce de
multiattention, celle qui est ordonnée
par les outils qu'on sait.
Alors ça c'est quand même ça c'est la
guerre domestique concrète à laquelle
nous avons tous affaire et moi je sais
que les premières perdons de cette
affaire ça va être mes copains
littéraires. C'est nous autres les qui
produisons des textes longs. Alors nous
on va être les premiers à passer à la
trappe ça je le sais hein.
Tu trompes peut-être non ? Regarde, nous
on fait des interviews longues et on
cartonne.
Ça, j'en suis convaincu. Mais attention
hein,
ça je l'ai toujours j'ai toujours
abander dans le sens quand je voyais les
les journaux ou les pur players ou les
gens qui font des des journaux en ligne
ou des vidéos en ligne, je les voyais
écourter leur truc, faire des produits
de 3 minutes. Mais vous êtes con quoi,
ça serait le moment ou jamais de faire 2
heures. Et je suis très content donc
vous n'es pas cédé à ça. Mais d'abord,
tu t'aperçois que c'est quand même rare.
Tu as remarqué ?
On est seul.
Voilà.
Moi, je crois qu'il y a beaucoup de gens
des des des énergumaine comme moi qui
sont capables de regarder une conférence
de l'ordon du heure 3/4 en vidéo, tu
vois. Mais parce que je viens de l'autre
siècle. Voilà, encore une fois sur le
reste et puis après l'attention porter
un texte c'est quand même autre chose
quoi. Donc moi pour moi une journée est
gagnée si j'ai réussi à me concentrer
durablement sur quelque chose dans ma
journée. Me concentrer durablement sur
le même objet pendant une 2 3 4 heur
dans ma journée.
Est-ce qu'on a tous une deux 3 4 heures
dans nos journées où on s'est concentré
sur le même objet, c'est-à-dire un
bouquin, un film, je sais pas, tel sujet
qu'on explore,
c'est ça quand même la guerre domestique
qui faut qu'on mène tous là. le
le combat aussi pour la l'introspection.
Se concentrer durablement sur quelque
chose, ça peut être sur soi-même. Ça
peut être c'est ce que dit Bernanos que
j'ai relu récemment qui récemment, il a
fait un livre contre les robots, la
France contre les robots. Bernos en 42
ou tr ou qu je sais plus. Enfin très
très visionnaire Bernard qu'à priori
c'est quand même le mec catholique
royaliste. Enfin c'est pas le mec qui
était qu'on aurait qu'on aurait désigné
comme favori pour anticiper sur
l'avenir. Livre extraordinaire où il dit
la vie moderne ou la la comment il dit
ça ? Je sais pas si c'est la modernité.
Peut-être la modernité est une
conspiration contre la vie intérieure.
C'est du Bernano, ça va loin, c'est un
peu hyperbolique. Il y va, il va fort.
Il a du souffle George. Et peut-être
qu'il exagère mais il y a quelque chose
qui se dit là-dedans quand même.
François Begodo, merci.
Merci.
[Musique]